former insurance executive cassadaga has
traded his expensive car for a bicycle
and he's given up the suits and hundred
thousand euro a year salary fruit image
done in boo hoo it's fun in my office I
felt like a king with my French cuffs
and custom tailored suits but it just
wasn't enough what a patient ish he quit
his job and started an apprenticeship as
a carpenter he was 40 years old he got
some funny looks but he went through
with it as a Finn who design at first
I'd stumble around the workshop I dipped
a few things over and got my klutzy legs
caught in the sawhorses I'm still done
hangin even the journeyman asked me why
I was taking orders from him he was 23 I
said because you know what you're doing
but yet I in 20 years he's a valid [ __ ]
carstens now completed his training and
started work in a little woodworking
shop in Berlin's courts bag district he
wanted to make things with his own hands
as an apprentice he was earning about
300 euros a month at age 43 how can
anyone live on that he's at me I don't
know all that yes mam first of all I'd
saved up a bit they're not to heal then
I parted with a few things that brought
in some money um daddy and then I had an
arrangement with my old company to get a
few more months pay I need him or not
the right outside heart toward the end
of my training I was getting more and
more panicky but somehow it worked out
and then oh um s kid let's get em Oh
Susanna gala has also made a new start
she founded a company that specializes
in coaching she used to be the managing
director of the Lutheran Church of
Berlin she was a civil servant and set
for life
but after 20 years on the job she quit
much to the dismay of her co-workers
from [ __ ] bucket they said are you nuts
you can't do that what are you going to
do with yourself but I'd already
considered what would happen if I didn't
make enough money to finance my life ok
then I work as a maid or saleswoman all
she knew was that she'd never work at a
civil service job again her old job had
felt like a straitjacket at 48 she had
felt buried alive as a madhab I thought
employees and even managers don't always
have the freedom to make decisions
quickly and efficiently and quite often
I noticed it wasn't even about the issue
it was more about the person involved
Gordon Susannah got sick of seeing
decisions made according to personal
preference now she coaches people who
are dissatisfied with her jobs she hopes
to share her experience and insights the
third spectrum I'm aiming for an
independent work situation to be able to
decide when and how long I work and with
whom to have the freedom to decide what
I do and vouch for my own quality um
felita time 15 cars digger sees more of
life in the world around him as he bikes
through the city
completa and shun evil I'm going for
complete deceleration without stepping
on the brakes there are people who say
they're going to keep doing what they've
always done but I like to try out new
things Roy is a gun on game he probably
won't be trying on any new suits and
ties he enjoys his newfound freedom